[Música]
y
hola américa latina' bienvenidos a kobe
19 la semana en américa el espacio de
france 24 en el que hacemos un resumen
de los hechos más destacados
relacionados con la pandemia del cob y
19 en nuestro continente a continuación
los temas que trataremos en esta edición
hablaremos de el plan presentado por el
presidente de eeuu joe biden para hacer
frente a la pandemia de kobe 19 en ese
país una de sus grandes promesas de
campaña y una apuesta para el inicio de
mandato que compromete una enorme escala
nacional de vacunación y de otros
sistemas para poder hacer frente a la
crisis sanitaria
vamos a ver entonces también cómo está
avanzando allí el tema de los contagios
y la cifra de personas fallecidas a lo
largo de esta semana porque superaron
todos los récords en ese país también
daremos un vistazo al avance de las
vacunas en la región de américa latina
panamá ya ecuador también se sumaron ya
a la lista de países que han comenzado a
inocular a sus ciudadanos un proceso que
no está lejos de la controversia esto
mientras otros países demoran la
inoculación por temas logísticos y
también legislativos
contamos de cuales se trata y les
tenemos la historia de una clínica en
santiago de chile- encargada de
falsificar resultados negativos de
pruebas de kobe 19 para viajeros que
necesitan comprobar que están libres de
coronavirus para visitar otros países o
también ahora irse a otras regiones de
chile tenemos el caso no lo va a contar
nuestra corresponsal allí en la capital
chilena patricia luna pues esos son
algunos de los temas vamos entonces a
comenzar como les iba comentando el
presidente de eeuu joe biden
no ha perdido un minuto para tomar
decisiones y dar inicio a diferentes
políticas en diferentes áreas tras una
serie de 17 órdenes ejecutivas firmadas
hace ya unos días y otras 10 que firmó
el día de ayer se enfocan en ofrecer una
respuesta coordinada a nivel federal
para combatir la pandemia del jove y 19
entre estas medidas se incluye exigir
una prueba de pcr negativa y también una
cuarentena a todas las personas que
lleguen a eeuu y también utilizar ley de
producción de defensa para la
fabricación de vacunas
esto se suma a otras decisiones de la
nueva administración que también incluye
el regreso de eeuu a la organización
mundial de la salud y al fondo de acceso
global para las vacunas de kobe 19
conocido como kóvacs sin embargo joe
biden asegura que la situación empeorará
antes de comenzar a mostrar síntomas de
mejoría
y las cosas van a continuar poniéndose
peor antes de que mejore hoy el memorial
que tuvimos hace un par de noches
desafortunadamente no será el último sur
la cantidad de muertos muy posiblemente
superará los 500 mil para el próximo mes
y los casos seguirán aumentando bien no
vamos a salir de esta situación de la
noche a la mañana
iba a tomar meses arreglar las cosas
pero déjenme ser claro vamos a superar
esto vamos a derrotar la pandemia del
fitness pm como ya lo decíamos eeuu
anunció que se incorporará al fondo
kóvacs este es un fondo de la
organización mundial de la salud este
programa fue presentado en 2020 para
asegurar un reparto equitativo de las
vacunas contra kobe y 19 entre los
diferentes países particularmente
beneficia a los países que no tienen una
capacidad de compra de las vacunas en
los mercados siendo estados unidos el
país con la mayor incidencia de casos a
nivel internacional era de esperarse que
participara en este fondo
kóvacs es el acrónimo en inglés del
fondo de acceso global para la vacuna
contra el cob y 19 es una iniciativa
público-privada creada en 2020 a través
de la o ms ante la necesidad de que la
vacuna llegue al mayor número de
personas en todo el mundo de manera
rápida y justa
bajo el lema solo estamos a salvo cuando
todos estamos a salvo su principal meta
es disponer de 2 mil millones de dosis
para finales de 2021 todos los países
participantes recibirán acceso a las
vacunas de manera proporcional a su
población independientemente de su nivel
socioeconómico
si bien presta especial atención a los
sectores de riesgo y a los países que no
podrían pagarlas a su precio de mercado
el mecanismo
el objetivo del mecanismo suministrar al
menos dos mil millones de dosis de
vacunas seguras y eficaces para finales
de 2000 21 twenty one of governance
mientras los gobiernos invierten
millones en estímulos económicos
el mecanismo kóvacs ofrece un enorme
retorno de la inversión hay luz al final
del túnel
para conseguir el reparto equitativo
kóvacs lanzó junto a la alianza para la
vacunación un programa de financiación
para 92 países con un producto interno
bruto per cápita por debajo de los 4 mil
dólares que recibirán 2 y subvencionadas
por parte de los países participantes en
el proyecto sin embargo es tener el
director general de la oms se quejó de
la falta de compromiso de algunos países
y compañías farmacéuticas y updates pitt
aunque hablen el idioma del acceso
equitativo a algunos países y empresas
siguen dando prioridad a los acuerdos
bilaterales pasando por encima de kóvacs
haciendo subir los precios e intentando
ponerse a la cabeza de la cola esto es
un error es el anuncio del nuevo
gobierno de eeuu de unirse a esta
iniciativa podría dotar al proyecto de
un nuevo impulso a nivel internacional
vamos a conocer más detalles de la
situación en eeuu con cristóbal vázquez
nuestro corresponsal en la ciudad de
washington
hola cristóbal cómo fue recibido este
plan de la administración by the end
para hacer frente como ya lo decíamos a
la pandemia en ese país y que más
detalles nos puede dar de eso
durante el primer día de gobierno
completo de baile en el nuevo presidente
publicó una estrategia nacional para
lograr controlar la pandemia que empieza
con una campaña de vacunación en la que
bailén quiere administrar 100 millones
de vacunas en los primeros 100 días de
su gobierno el plan también incluye
nuevos requisitos de viaje como pedirle
a viajeros internacionales una prueba
negativa del cobat antes de entrar al
país y aumentar los recursos para la
vacunación bailén firmó en este primer
día 10 órdenes ejecutivas memorandos y
directrices enfocadas en hacer frente a
la pandemia bailén además firmó una
orden ejecutiva que obliga a los
estadounidenses a portar máscara en
edificios y en jurisdicción federal
además adelanta medidas para que los
viajeros nacionales tengan que usar un
protector visual y una máscara cuando
viajen en trenes aviones y buses bailén
aseguró que los especialistas son los
que van a tener la palabra y la libertad
pues planear y contrarrestar la pandemia
sin tener interferencia política para
que ellos tomen las decisiones adecuadas
para el país
cristóbal y cómo está avanzando el plan
de vacunación que venía en marcha de la
administración anterior
la meta del presidente o alguien es
poner un millón de vacunas al día en los
primeros 100 días es muy baja según
expertos que argumentan que de ser así
decenas de millones de dosis se quedarán
sin usarse y es que según datos de los
centros de control y prevención de
enfermedades ya se alcanzó este objetivo
y el promedio de vacunación al día es de
911 mil personas esto además teniendo en
cuenta que sólo el 46 por ciento de las
vacunas disponibles se están
administrando y que según expertos con
un régimen eficaz de vacunación se
pueden distribuir hasta 2 millones de
dosis al día según oficiales de fisión y
de moderna en este momento las
farmacéuticas están en plena capacidad
de producción ofreciendo 18 millones de
dosis a la semana expertos estiman que
para marzo hayan entregado 200 millones
de vacunas esto sin sumar las dosis de
vacunas de johnson y johnson que están
en proceso de aprobación bailén le está
pidiendo además al congreso 20.000
millones de dólares para ampliar centros
de vacunación en todo eeuu estadios
clínic
las móviles y otros lugares además
quiere contratar 100 mil trabajadores
para que ayuden en todo este plan de
vacunación cristóbal hagamos un balance
de la situación en eeuu hasta ahora le
hago la pregunta porque a lo largo de
esta semana este país batió todos los
récords un día tras otro en cuanto a
personas contagiadas y personas
fallecidas por kobe 19
en eeuu hay un promedio de contagio en
este momento de 160.000 personas al día
aunque desde el 15 de enero la cifra ha
empezado a bajar y analistas dicen que
ya se llegó al pico y que ahora los
casos van a empezar a bajar en total los
casos están en cerca de 25 millones y en
los últimos 7 días hubo un millón 300
mil casos la cifra de muertos ya supera
las 410 mil personas y roger gual en si
la nueva directora del centro de control
y prevención de enfermedades de eeuu
dijo que para el primero de febrero
habrá más de medio millón de casos en
cuanto a los recuperados hay cerca de
10,8 millones de personas
gracias francisco cristóbal por este
informe desde la ciudad de washington
avanzamos con otros temas también fue
destacado esta semana en eeuu el
homenaje que el presidente joe biden y
su vicepresidenta kamala harris
rindieron a las más de 412.000 víctimas
que deja hasta el momento el kobe 19 en
ese país el propio mandatario como
también ya nos decía cristóbal indicó
que la cifra de personas fallecidas
podría llegar al medio millón para el
próximo mes más detalles de la situación
de este país en el siguiente reportaje
el empire state building se iluminó de
rojo para representar los latidos del
corazón y en honor a los 400.000
estadounidenses que han muerto de kobe
[Música]
las campanas de la catedral nacional de
washington sonaron 400 veces un
campanazo por cada mil vidas perdidas
al interior una escultura con
cuatrocientos mil pájaros de papel
huelga del techo por todos aquellos que
han perdido la batalla contra el kobe 19
la estatua de la libertad también se
iluminó el número de muertes que ha
dejado la pandemia hasta ahora en eeuu
es mayor que la población de nueva
orleans cleveland o tampa hasta el lunes
los estados de arizona carolina del sur
nueva york oklahoma y california habían
reportado la mayor cantidad de casos
nuevos per cápita durante la semana
anterior
sin embargo california que ese día se
convirtió en el primer estado en
registrar más de 3 millones de positivos
por coronavirus ahora tiene una caída
del 10 por ciento en el número de casos
por supuesto que queremos ver esto lo
más bajo posible tanto como sea posible
pero la buena noticia es que estamos en
una postura en la que la propagación del
cómic no está creciendo en el estado
sino disminuyendo un poco más despacio
de lo que quisiéramos
el ritmo al que los estadounidenses han
estado muriendo se aceleró durante el
otoño y el invierno y alcanzó a niveles
récord en enero después de la
celebración de acción de gracias' y las
vacaciones de fin de año y ahora pasemos
a nuestra región américa latina en donde
también avanzan los planes de vacunación
contra el jove y 19 hasta el momento
méxico costa rica panamá ecuador chile
argentina y brasil son los únicos que ya
han puesto en marcha sus respectivos
planes de inmunización hay gran
expectativa en colombia por una posible
llegada del primer lote de vacunas para
el mes de febrero al igual que en perú
en donde allí hay una controversia en
torno a la capacidad de la
infraestructura hospitalaria para llevar
a cabo este plan de inmunización a gran
escala nacional
y como ya lo decíamos panamá inició con
su primer lote de doce mil ochocientos
cuarenta dosis de vacunas de la
farmacéutica pfiezer variante contra el
cobre 19 un proceso de inmunización a
gran escala se convirtió así en el
segundo país de centroamérica en poner
en marcha un proceso de vacunación para
combatir la pandemia una enfermera de 59
años que trabaja en una unidad de
cuidados intensivos de un hospital
público de la ciudad de panamá fue la
primera ciudadana en ser inoculada
aunque el lote recibido es mucho menor a
40.000 dosis que habían adquirido
inicialmente panamá ya puede combatir la
pandemia desde otro frente mientras
mantiene también medidas de bioseguridad
y algunas restricciones en las ciudades
sobre todo en la capital y en la zona de
panamá este en donde está la mayor
concentración de habitantes en ese país
en esta fase obviamente
especialmente médico y enfermera técnico
vinculado directamente
al tema de la pandemia
y así vamos a ir por eso que se llama la
estrategia
continua
pero condicionada a las estrellas por
las diferentes del aura y esta semana
también dimos a conocer esas
impresionantes imágenes que llegaban
desde la ciudad de manaos la ciudad más
grande de la amazonas brasileño en donde
está escaseando el oxígeno la crisis
desató el caos en los hospitales que
tienen dificultades para poder atender a
los pacientes afectados por el cob y 19
esta es la situación
a pocos kilómetros del caos de la
megalópolis amazónica la pequeña ciudad
de iranduba aparece muy tranquila aquí
las autoridades han impuesto un toque de
queda durante una semana desde las 2 de
la tarde las calles están desiertas el
hospital de la ciudad tiene el 90% de
sus camas ocupadas la situación es seria
para esta familia de comerciantes no
tenemos una unidad de cuidados
intensivos
si la teníamos pero único funcionó sin
ninguna unidad de cuidados intensivos y
con más de 3400 positivos y 60 decesos
en pocas semanas iranduba hace todo para
que funcione el transporte público a
managua está prohibido la patrulla sólo
tiene una instrucción tolerancia a 0
tienes que ir a casa hoy te doy un
simple consejo pero si vuelve a suceder
serás detenido
por favor ponte esta mascarilla aquí
y los que nunca han padecido la
enfermedad en casa piensan que es una
broma que no hay proliferación del virus
así que es un trabajo duro pero sobre
todo educativo
el capitán no tiene intención de que su
ciudad sea contagiada por manaos
con todos los medios que tienen en
manaos están en una situación complicada
así que estamos haciendo todo lo posible
para evitar llegar a este nivel iranduba
ha logrado asegurar un valioso
suministro de oxígeno en manaus frente a
esta empresa privada cientos de
parientes enfermos esperan durante horas
un recambio del preciado gas
miren los que puedan dejar sus tanques
háganlo por qué no podemos llenarlos
hasta mañana por la tarde una triste
rutina para el dueño desearía no tener
que llorar con todo el mundo
querida querida mía hoy no hay enemigo
amigo pues rico o pobre soy el proveedor
oficial del estado vecino
manaos ha tenido un contrato con otra
compañía durante 50 años
deberías preguntarles por qué hay falta
de oxígeno son una empresa multinacional
el mayor proveedor del mundo no había
razón para hacerle esto a nuestra ciudad
pronto serán las 7 de la tarde hora del
toque de queda
xavi avelina ha estado esperando más de
8 horas no conseguirá oxígeno para su
padre esta noche
llegué a las 11 y me las arreglé para
conseguir una pipeta para salvar a mi
padre y a un amigo una experiencia
devastadora
[Aplausos]
experiencia devastadora
el gobernador de la región ha advertido
que hay que actuar rápidamente
autorizado otras semanas de suspenso la
vacuna china ha llegado por fin a la
capital amazónica vamos a conocer más
detalles de la situación en brasil con
valeria saccone nuestra corresponsable
en la ciudad del río de janeiro o la
valeria y quiero comenzar preguntándole
por el avance que ha tenido en este país
el plan de vacunación a nivel nacional
siendo brasil uno de los países más
afectados a nivel mundial por la
pandemia y en donde viven casi 209
millones de personas
brasil lleva toda la semana vacunando a
sus profesionales sanitarios a los
indígenas y a los ancianos de momento
están disponibles para una población de
212 millones de habitantes tan solo 6
millones de dosis de la corona vaca la
vacuna china importada por el gobernador
de sampaolo yo autor ya sin embargo hoy
la anvisa que es el órgano regulador del
ministerio de sanidad también ha
aprobado el uso de emergencia de a otras
48 millones de dosis de la misma vacuna
que han sido envasadas en brasil por el
laboratorio por el instituto butantán de
sao paulo además hay otra buena noticia
han llegado de la india- dos millones de
dosis de la otra vacuna aprobada la de
oxford desarrollada por el laboratorio
astrazéneca ha habido a lo largo de la
semana ciertos problemas diplomáticos
porque por lo visto el gobierno de jair
bolsonaro no apoyó a la india en su
petición de liberar la patente de estas
vacunas entonces ha habido como un
rifirrafe entre los dos países
finalmente se han enviado esas vacunas
pero queda un problema de fondo
que todas las materias primas del
principio activo son producidas en china
y en la india y las relaciones
diplomáticas con ambos países no son
excelentes hay que recordar que en jr
bolsonaro por razones ideológicas ha
criticado en varias ocasiones al
gobierno chino tanto él como su ministro
de exteriores y eso no ayuda a la hora
de conseguir más vacunas
valeria hace unos minutos veíamos la
crisis en la ciudad de manaos como está
allí la situación hasta esta hora qué
novedades hay
en manaos la situación sigue tensa el
suministro de oxígeno no ha vuelto a sus
niveles normales esa ha sido la causa de
la muerte de varios pacientes y también
la caza del traslado de otros tantos a
otros estados federados del país con la
ayuda de las fuerzas armadas la
situación no mejora desde el inicio de
la crisis sanitaria amazonas que es el
estado de manaos ha superado ya los
7.000 muertos un dato muy triste en una
región que no tiene mucha población y
hay otra noticia que preocupa la
vacunación del personal sanitario ha
sido suspendida temporalmente por
irregularidades eso quiere decir que hay
personas que no entraban en el grupo de
riesgo que han conseguido saltarse la
fila y es ha creado un malestar y por
cierto es algo que está aconteciendo en
otras partes de brasil
valeria en otros temas como recibieron
los cariocas la noticia de la
cancelación del carnaval de río de
janeiro debido precisamente a la
pandemia de kobe 19 ya la lenta
inmunización a nivel nacional
los cariocas intentan superar la
decepción porque es la segunda vez este
año que se cancela el carnaval no se
celebrará ni en febrero ni en julio pero
el alcalde de río de janeiro eduardo
paes ha sido contundente en el medio de
una pandemia no se puede convocar un
evento que llega a reunir a casi 10
millones de personas eso sí que se ha
mostrado triste porque es un fiestero
incluso toca un instrumento de percusión
en una de las principales escuelas de
samba de la ciudad pero él no ha querido
oír razones e intenta al mismo tiempo
compensar al sector económico
relacionado con una fiesta que genera
cada año millares de puestos de trabajo
y una facturación de 745 millones de
dólares hoy ha anunciado la convocatoria
de licitaciones públicas para ofrecer
una alternativa económica a estos
empresarios y a esos trabajadores pero
todavía no se conocen los detalles
valeria muchas gracias por este reporte
desde la ciudad de rio de janeiro de
brasil nos vamos hasta perú
allí el anuncio del presidente interino
francisco sagasti sobre la compra de las
vacunas contra el kobe 19 ha generado
todo tipo de controversias a nivel local
esto mientras los contagios y también
los fallecidos por el coronavirus siguen
aumentando muy bueno una gran parte de
la población de este país se niega a ser
inoculada
el presidente francisco sagasti anunció
que perú comprará scinopharm de china 38
millones de dosis de su vacuna contra el
hobbit 19 y también adquirirá 14
millones de dosis del medicamento
producido por oxford astrazéneca de
inglaterra los ensayos clínicos de fase
3 realizados en el perú no sólo nos han
colocado en una mejor posición para
acceder a las vacunas de scinopharm sino
que también nos han servido para
comprobar su efectividad en la población
nacional de esta manera esperamos tener
vacunados entre 14 y 15 millones de
peruanos antes de que arrecie la
temporada de invierno en nuestro país
las vacunas han sido cuestionadas y
rechazadas por algunos congresistas
quienes interpondrán una demanda de
inconstitucionalidad contra la ley que
sustenta la compra en mi persona va a
plantear
la demanda de inconstitucionalidad
porque esta vacuna es una vacuna
insegura no ha pasado la fase 3 de
experimentación de investigación ya no
tiene los estudios concluidos es una
vacuna que va a poner en riesgo la salud
a la población pero sufre la segunda ola
de la pandemia del cobi 19 con más de un
millón de contagiados y alrededor de
40.000 muertos por coronavirus sin
embargo un 48% de peruanos se niega a
recibir la vacuna no me pienso vacunar
porque no estoy preparada en primer
lugar y pienso que este es como un
conejillo de indias tengo dudas acerca
del eficacia de la vacuna hay mucho
posibles vacunas pero no se han dado los
resultados exactos otros peruanos se
muestran favorables como en otros países
se pide al gobierno mayor información y
campañas educativas sobre la necesidad
de que la vacunación sea masiva quieren
conocer más sobre la seguridad y la
garantía de esa vacuna para vacunar yo
estoy dispuesto a vacunar porque soy una
persona ya que fuera hay gente que no
está bien informado parece que no
quieren
llevemos vacunarlos todos piden
vacunarse todos el primer lote de
vacunas que sino farm envia perú es de
un millón de dosis servirá para
inmunizar al personal sanitario miembros
de la policía y las fuerzas armadas
y ecuador también se sumó a la lista de
países de américa del sur que recibió ya
los primeros lotes de vacunas contra el
cob y 19 y que pone en marcha un plan
nacional de inmunización como ya lo ha
hecho chile como ya lo ha hecho también
brasil a argentina y méjico esto
mientras la ocupación de las salas
usi llega ya al 85% las autoridades
sanitarias en ese país libran una
carrera contra el reloj para mantener
las cadenas de frío que requieren las
vacunas de la farmacéutica pfiezer que
fue distribuida en quito guayaquil y
cuenca que son las tres ciudades más
grandes del país así comenzó este plan
de vacunación a gran escala en ese país
es la noticia más esperada en ecuador
son las primeras 8.000 dosis de las
vacunas contra el 19 la primera entrega
de las 86 mil que llegan al país hasta
el mes de marzo estuvimos para
presenciar el momento en quien dijeron
el mundo cierra pero también estamos
para presenciar el momento en que vemos
llegar la luz
el ecuador es el segundo país en recibir
la vacuna pzifer de américa del sur
hoy empieza el proceso de vacunación en
el ecuador pero con ellas llega también
un gran reto
mantenerlas a la temperatura requerida
menos 70 grados centígrados se usará
hielo seco mientras llegan congeladores
importados y alemania
programa es una de las estratégica para
aquí en nuestra zona distribución
colocar ocho congeladores que almacenan
hasta dos millones de vacunas los
congeladores tienen temperaturas de
menos 80 grados menos 20 y de menos 28
grados que son lo que requieren las
farmacéuticas son las que van a traer
las vacunas las primeras dosis llegan
cuando se registra un 85 por ciento de
ocupación y unidades de cuidados
intensivos a nivel nacional y sin que
exista una estrategia clara de
vacunación según este especialista
nosotros acabamos de publicar un reporte
de los primeros 10.000 pacientes en el
ecuador y pues en base a este estudio
nosotros hemos visto que ciertos grupos
poblacionales tienen menos riesgo de
morir entonces cuando tienes 80 mil
vacunas tú tienes que ver la forma hasta
filosófica y ética de asignar vacunas
escasísimas para una población con
demandas altísimas
las primeras vacunas se distribuirán
entre quito guayaquil y cuenca con ellas
llega un rayo de esperanza juro que por
ahora es tenue pues ecuador necesita
vacunar al 65% de su población
vamos a conocer más detalles de la
situación en ecuador allí se encuentra
gustavo ortega en la ciudad de quito
hola gustavo pues la novedad es la
puesta en marcha de este plan de
vacunación como ha avanzado esta
inmunización allí en ecuador
sí buenas noches para ti la novedad no
ha escapado inclusive de diferencias
entre especialistas y quienes ven la
llegada de las vacunas con esperanzas
ecuador inició el proceso de vacunación
o fase 0 tal y como lo ha indicado el
ministro de la salud esto también se ha
indicado es que seguirá incrementando
los puntos de vacunación pero también
decepcionó un poco la llegada de las
vacunas porque se había ni inclusive
dicho que iban a llegar a 86 mil 12 es
todo esto para inocular a 43 mil
personas pero llegaron 8 mil dosis luego
inclusive de haber dicho anteriormente
que llegarían 15 mil dosis semanales esa
información no ha sido actualizada sólo
llegaron 8 mil dosis y se espera que
hasta el mes de febrero lleguen las 86
mil dosis de la farmacéutica pfiezer ha
comenzado progresivamente en quito
guayaquil y cuenca e inclusive en el
hospital militar la jefa del servicio de
emergencia fue la primera mujer en
ecuador quien recibió la dosis de la
vacuna contra la cob y 19 de igual forma
también fueron 36 médicos en las
de que comenzaron a recibir estas dosis
de igual forma también han habido
críticas porque en conversación con
especialistas nos han dicho que 86 mil
dosis hasta el mes de febrero e
inclusive muy poco para inocular a
43.000 personas pero se ha establecido
un perfil para poder así vacunar a mi
personal de primera línea caballeros
enfermeros personales de recolección de
desechos sólidos en los distintos
hospitales se intenta llegar hasta en
tres semanas la activación de 93 centros
y 95 centros de salud para poder aplicar
así las vacunas en las principales
ciudades del país quito guayaquil y
cuenca lo cierto es que el país espera
iniciar hasta el principio del mes de
marzo una vacunación masiva para emplear
de 86 mil dosis a 2 millones de dosis
para comenzar así la vacunación masiva y
por supuesto hay nerviosismo hay
ansiedad y hay esperanza la alguien por
la llegada de las dosis santiago gustavo
al inicio de la pandemia veíamos la
crisis que tuvo guayaquil las alturas
de los centros asistenciales a lo largo
y ancho de ecuador como está la
ocupación de la sala sushi y de los
hospitales en todo el país que siguen
aguardando a que llegue la vacuna hasta
las diferentes regiones
pero específicamente el día de ayer el
ministro de salud expresaba que la
ocupación a nivel nacional de los
hospitales se ha elevado de un 85 a un
95 por ciento específicamente en las
unidades de cuidados intensivos y en las
zonas de hospitalización se habla un 56%
a nivel nacional pero la situación se ha
incrementado de forma más crítica
específicamente en la ciudad de quito
donde ya hay 3 hospitales que no tienen
camas disponibles inclusive se reciben
150 pacientes diarios santiago gustamos
muchas gracias por este reporte desde
quitó avanzó con otros temas que tenemos
para este programa las cifras que dan a
conocer las autoridades de colombia no
son alentadoras este país contabiliza
más de 50 mil fallecidos por cuenta del
joven 19 colombia asuma así y se
aproxima rápidamente a los 2 millones de
casos de kobe 19 ya están 1.9 millones
de casos confirmados según lo dicen las
autoridades colombia espera recibir sus
primeros lotes de vacunas
el mes de febrero este país ha adquirido
vacunas desarrolladas por facer variante
oxford astrazéneca y jensen
la próxima semana se definirá qué países
van a recibir estas vacunas la primera
semana de febrero y colombia está en
este grupo de países porque cumplen los
criterios que han sido considerados
estar el país listo para iniciar la
vacunación inmediatamente llega a la
vacuna el tener la infraestructura para
la conservación de las vacunas como es
el caso de la vacuna del laboratorio de
fase iib intech y no haber iniciado la
vacunación a esta fecha y esta historia
resulta muy insólita en el contexto de
emergencia sanitaria en el que estamos
un centro médico de santiago la capital
de chile fue denunciado por falsificar
certificados y resultados de pruebas de
kobe 19 negativos los cuales
comercializaba por el orden de 85
dólares cada uno los viajeros hacia
otros países o también hacia otras
regiones de chile eran los principales
clientes de esta clínica fraudulenta del
caso ha escandalizado a toda la sociedad
chilena y por supuesto a las autoridades
de salud patricia luna allí en la
capital chilena nos da más detalles de
esta situación
gran revuelo generado en chile
especialmente en redes sociales el
conocimiento de que existía una clínica
privada en el barrio adinerado
santiaguino de las condes que realizaba
pcr es negativos falsos
es decir entregaba un resultado negativo
sin que uno tuviera que atravesar ese
incómodo momento en que los tubos son
introducidos por la nariz y la garganta
para tomar las muestras el hecho fue
descubierto por un vecino que estaba
cotizando servicios y que no entendía
por qué esta clínica en concreto careful
home tardaba tan solo una hora en
entregar un resultado mientras que el
resto de los servicios que cotizó
demoraba entre 24 y 48 horas cuando
entendió lo que estaba ocurriendo
realizó una denuncia ante la autoridad
sanitaria de la región metropolitana y
fue la propia seremi de salud palabra la
que se presentó en la clínica para
clausurarla y para anunciar querellas
por parte de la autoridad sanitaria
contra todos aquellos que resulten
responsables mientras que la clínica
afirma que era algo que estaba
realizando uno de sus empleados sin que
ellos tuvieran conocimiento la realidad
es que tanto la clínica como es empleado
en concreto como aquellas personas que
compraron los pcr es negativo
falsos enfrentan según la investigación
que lleva ahora mismo la fiscalía a
penas que pueden ir desde la cárcel
efectiva hasta multas de 14 mil dólares
en el peor de los casos patricia luna
informándonos desde santiago la capital
chilena en nuestra sección en redes
veamos otras noticias destacadas de la
semana aquí en kobe 19 la semana en
américa comenzamos en nuestro portal
france24 puntocom inequidad el talón de
aquiles en la distribución de vacunas
contra el kobe 19 un reclamo que han
hecho las autoridades se han pedido un
poco más de equilibrio en el reparto de
las vacunas a nivel mundial el organismo
de la o ms alertó que el plan de
inmunización podría ser un fracaso si
los más vulnerables no acceden a la
vacuna y pierden su vida de las más de
39 millones de dosis que han sido
administradas hasta ahora solamente el
1% ha sido aplicada a pacientes de
países considerados menos favorecidos
económicamente
avanzamos con otros temas que los países
pobres tengan acceso a la vacuna es una
cuestión de equidad global más o menos
en sintonía con el mismo tema son
algunas declaraciones dadas por
francisco becerra ex subdirector de la
opc y también consultor en salud pública
quien concedió una entrevista exclusiva
a nuestra cadena la pueden ver completa
en la página web france24 puntocom
y otro tema destacado de la semana la
nación de costa rica- título esta semana
tasa de contagio de kobe 19 en costa
rica desciende a sus niveles más bajos
en tres meses según la universidad
hispanoamericana indica una disminución
en el contagio que llega al 25.8 por
ciento en relación con semanas
anteriores el artículo indica que el
comportamiento de los costarricenses y
también la cantidad de pruebas
realizadas puede incluir o puede ser
parte de este descenso en el porcentaje
también este es un país que avanza en su
proceso de vacunación a nivel nacional
sobre todo haciendo énfasis en el valle
central que es donde se ubica la mayor
cantidad de habitantes
es todo por el momento aquí en kobe 19
la semana en américa nos vemos la
próxima semana siguen con france24
[Música]